mercredi matin sur le campus de
l'université mcgill un prof et son
étudiant seront à la réunion
hebdomadaire d'un groupe de recherche
rien de plus banal il s'agit d'un groupe
de recherche unique au monde qui
enseigne matière fort exigeante par les
temps qui courent l'espoir quand on perd
l'espoir on va être toute possibilité de
changer les choses sur le terrain donc
je pense que des personnes comme adnane
et tous les stagiaires qui font partie
de notre gamme c des personnes qui me
peu importe la situation ont gardé cet
espoir là ils vont chercher à travailler
ensemble pour améliorer la situation
dans la communauté
région palestine/israël l'assuré israël
jordanie
montréal québec israël palestine halte
est vrai quand on est un palestinien de
gaza ou de naplouse on ne rencontre pas
souvent d'israéliens c'est l'idée
derrière ce groupe de recherche en
travail social c'est-à-dire réunit des
leaders de la société civile de par tout
moyen orient dans une sorte de zone
franche
ici à montréal
ici je me sens bien plus comme faisant
partie du moyen orient que lorsque je
suis en israël parce qu'ici je peux
rencontrer non seulement des
palestiniens mais aussi des citoyens de
tous les pays du moyen-orient
c'est triste et c'est pourquoi on veut
changer ça cette expérience qu'on vit
ici renforce et encourage le
développement degré plus que tout autre
endroit
allez place mais je crois que à la base
de tous les conflits
c'est vraiment une question de manque de
à notre connaissance de la perspective
de l'autre et ce que nous visons ici ce
que tous les stagiaires qui viennent
participer dans ce programme vise c'est
vraiment de pouvoir développer justement
à une connaissance beaucoup plus
profonde à la réalité de l'autre le
fruit dont stand à leurs preuves
si on ne se tient pas debout pour
dénoncer les injustices on en est
complice le aykan miguil c'est l'idée de
james toxines air professeur
littéralement d'activisme sociale
guillaume bastille où on le voit ici
dans les années 80 lors d'une campagne
pour dénoncer les méthodes inquisitrice
des agents du bien-être social rebaptisé
les boubous macoutes ou encore dans
cette manifestation à gaza pour l'accès
des enfants handicapés à l'école et pour
le think tank verte depuis les gens
croient que faire la paix est hors de
leur portée que c'est la sphère des
politiciens ce que nous faisons ici
c'est d'apprendre au contraire qu'on
peut contribuer à la paix au quotidien à
petite échelle
autour de nous dur à avaler fin du set
up des tories one à mal l sanaa et le
bras droit du professeur toxines air à
17 ans cette bergère de palestine
mettait sur pied le premier organisme
d'alphabétisation pour les femmes
bédouines
aujourd'hui elle organise des stages des
étudiants dans divers organismes des de
chine aide aux immigrants aux femmes
battues aux pauvres bref ils apprennent
ici comment défendre la veuve et
l'orphelin
c'est vraiment une ville multiethnique
qui a beaucoup d'enjeux aussi auquel les
gens à dans nos communautés s'y amarrer
elles font face et ils apprennent
énormément d organisation qui date
depuis très longtemps dans cette ville
qui travaillent dans nos communautés
pauvres montréal et ça ça leur donne des
techniques qui doivent nécessairement
adaptés alors contacté l'an prochain les
étudiants iront travailler dans lyon
centre d'action communautaire fondé par
des anciens étudiants du programme au
moyen-orient
c'est notre botte writing ball books
selon amal helsana on ne trouvera pas la
recette de la fée au moyen-orient dans
une thèse ou dans un autre livre mais
bien une action concrète n'égale contact
malgré le fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
voir en personne
c'est absolument impossible de traverser
les frontières dans la région
mais c'est l'évaluation humaines les
relations
entre nostalgie au fil des années qui
est à la base de notre succès le
contexte est tellement compliquée et
difficile que souvent ça prend un
endroit à l'extérieur et si un jour ces
amitiés improbables né à montréal
si un jour ces spécialistes de la
justice sociale a mené chez eux un peu
d'espoir de ramener la paix au moyen
orient
on pourrait se dire qu'il ya un peu nous
autres là dedans